welcome back to CBS this morning all
morning we've been reporting on the
terrible news from across the Pacific 49
people killed in Christchurch New
Zealand in a pair of shootings targeting
Muslims praying at two mosques a white
Australian is the main suspect in the
deadliest mass killing in that country's
history a law enforcement source tells
CBS News that Brenton Tarrant claims
others are planning more attacks on
mosques earlier this morning we spoke to
the host of CBS's The Amazing Race Phil
Keoghan he was raised born and raised in
Christchurch a city of nearly 400,000
people we reached fill by Skype and
maharajah on New Zealand's North Island
and asked him about the Christchurch
community well Christchurch is the
largest city in the South Island of New
Zealand New Zealand's made up of two
primary islands it is the city that does
pride itself in having a very mixed
population we're a very tolerant country
I think is how you would describe New
Zealand a peaceful country certainly a
progressive country this is just not the
kind of place that you would expect to
see something like this this attack
targeted Muslims in your community who
are likely immigrants tell us about that
community's role and place in
Christchurch we are a country of
immigrants and we're a diverse country
and we pride ourselves in being
different we take pride in in in our
indigenous people and this is not
representative of who we are
the idea that they targeted Christchurch
I think speaks to if this manifesto that
he put together is in fact his he said
specifically that he wanted to do this
in a place like Christchurch because it
is the place that you would least expect
something like this happen can you tell
us about New Zealand's relationships
with guns yes from guns are very low gun
owners are around 250,000 I think of our
population of 4 million there are only a
hundred and sorry 1.5 million guns as
opposed to say in America where there
are enough guns for every man woman and
child in the entire country just to give
you some kind
persons of the numbers on the hall we're
not a violent country in that way you
mentioned in Christchurch is peaceful
young tolerant full of immigrants you
seem to be suggesting there's nothing in
Christchurch that this would grow out of
no if you were to ask me I mean not
being lucky enough to is a host of
Amazing Race and working in television
now for 30 years I've been lucky enough
to work in 130 countries around the
world and if you were to ask me the last
place that I would expect something like
this to happen it would be Christchurch
the 49 people killed in last night's
attack in Christchurch is more than the
number of murder victims for all of New
Zealand in 2017 of course we're thinking
of everyone in that country right now
going through this tragedy you think
about that number that you just said
yeah that really tells quite a story
about what life is like there and it was
interesting to hear from John Miller
though how all the way here in the
United States we are in close touch with
them we're beefing up security here at
home and we're trying to learn lessons
from this mm-hmm